and speaking of the devil here he comes
you talking some [ __ ] oh as always i
never change
essentially i was thinking actually um
and we can
we can play obviously you can play also
but i was thinking maybe we can do a
quick technique practice
so remember that no it's probably in
your nightmare still but when i gave up
the queen and you tried to beat me
yeah odds game that sounds good i was
thinking we should uh we should work a
little bit on your technique just not to
lose sight of it let me challenge you
and this will be another chance to beat
a gm so it's a win-win for you i'm going
to challenge you to a 10-minute game
so you can go um go e4
and now go knight f3
whoops all right all right here we go
the tension is palpable yeah
i'm looking for something kind of fat
but i don't think i'm gonna find
anything too noteworthy
and you've found something noteworthy in
the form of an extra queen
so you've done all the heavy heavy
lifting you really need to do now all
you need to do is follow principles
and there's i mean i might be a
geometers i'm going to try to play
tricks on you and unbalance the position
but
you always have to go back to like first
principles if you're occupying the
center developing your pieces
defending against threats stopping my
threats nothing bad is gonna happen to
you when you have an extra queen
yeah that makes sense so then i guess
another thing i need to work on is just
not going too hard when i have a lead
and like
accidentally making some yeah like this
fork right here well actually
it's fine you only lose one piece so
don't panic that's basically nothing
when i'm down a queen
and i kind of read your mind there you
forgot to ask yourself why did i play
rook to g8
okay i'm not i'm not your average
village village 800.
when i move my rook to g8 i actually
have a point
right so then i guess
now you need to ask yourself yeah go
ahead i was gonna say
the play i had in my head that i thought
was gonna make a lot of sense was
pushing queen over to g4 so if you took
one piece i'd take your rook but it's
protected by
knight and g4 is protected by the knight
yeah so the whole plan wouldn't work
because the night's there so then i
started asking myself how to get the
night off but i don't really have a good
way of doing that
yeah so you're going to lose a piece you
have two options you can at least take
out a pawn while you're at it or you
could say this okay i'm going to lose a
piece thanks for the subs guys and
you might as well trade trade as many
pieces as you can while you're at it so
if you're going to move your bishop away
for example could you move it on such a
square
that you at least get to orchestrate a
trade
yeah so i was bringing bishop here and
i'm gonna take your night big [ __ ] but
you're still up a queen for a piece so
you should still be able to win this
game
right the key the key word being should
we will will will okay well we'll see we
we will see about that yeah
okay
good move forcing me to move my king in
order to defend the pawn
yeah now use your extra queen i mean you
have an extra queen to use it
so i guess what i need to start
recognizing is the best places for her
so i can't really bring her too deep
over here on the gh side because it's
all protected by knight i can't go
g4 i can't go g5 or h5
so then right the only option left
brings me to f
three here that's a great option it's it
attacks tonight i i don't have too many
resources with which to
to keep my position together i do have
one which is the rook
you can now still you can use your queen
to keep tightening the screws combine
your queen with a knight also like
remember that the queen and the knight
are a very powerful combination so you
can use them together
to attack a lot of pieces at once that
makes sense
so what do you think of a move like this
to look to attack on c7
excellent and you're actually setting up
a fork
not only are you acting c7 now i have to
defend c7 because that pawn
i cannot afford to lose especially with
a queen
but i am sending you right in the
direction of what other
little mofo
look at the whole board don't get don't
fall in love with just c7
right right um
i guess i'm just not seeing it because
that pawn wasn't defending anything
besides the d5 which i can't access
since i
right look look elsewhere you're
attacking another pawn
again you're tunnel visioning on the
center and on the c7 pawn
but look at the king side there's a pawn
that's staring you right in the face
which you can just take
there's literally a pawn you can take
right now free pawn with your queen
all right so then it's just taking the
pieces that are given which is still the
lesson that i need to learn
yep that pawn on h4 and maybe part of it
is still your
your desire to do more than that you see
a pawn yeah it's not really too much i
want something more than just a pawn i
don't know how much of a role that plays
not to put words in your mouth
no that's something i've said before
like when i see just a hanging pawn or
something
i'll often just disregard it looking for
like a more advantageous yeah
and you're already at the stage where
you don't want to do that you pawns
have become a bigger deal than they were
when you were let's say 700 right
you can actually win a game now just by
like taking a bunch of pawns
so um i'm going to make a very tricky
move right now
that's all i'm going to say i'm going to
say it's going to be very tricky it
creates a threat
and your job is to identify this right
i'm going to go knight d4 here
i have an undefended pawn on c2
but i don't think that's the main threat
checking me at
ef2 doesn't work it's protected by my
knight
correct so far but you haven't quite
seen the threat yet
monk ass i have a you have much bigger
fish to fry than that c2 pawn let me
tell you
look at that my rook on g6 what is it
accomplishing
its attack it's threatening my g2 pawn
again it's not threatening it it's
pinning it yeah it's
holding it right which means the g2 pawn
is immobilized so what am i actually
threatening in this position
uh my queen by going out f3 very nice so
that is what you need to defend against
at all costs so
okay that makes sense
and you can do that in several ways you
can unpin that pawn that would be the
easiest way
because that would solve the disease as
well as the symptoms if you just move
your queen away
first of all you have no squares for
that queen second of all i could still
give you that unpleasant check on f3
so you see what i'm saying yeah okay so
in a situation like that just unpinning
is typically the best
is this one could say a six inch move i
i mean
more like a one inch move i mean but
but sometimes you have to oil the
machine you know what i'm saying
i don't think you know what i'm saying
but it's fine well you're making up
phrases i can i can
pick up the context clues of course well
you know
the high energy sort of alpha people
make up phrases that's just something
that that's done
um let me go
c6
and now you have you can put into action
one of i think what's becoming one of
your favorite plans right now
you need freaking squares for your
pieces you need to open stuff up in
order to exploit that extra queen
yeah which is pushing that pawn on f2
yeah
no but this what you have a piece that's
hanging you still have that f7 pawn
that's undefended i could take with a
bishop which threatens rook
[ __ ] i missed that that's the best move
actually oh my god that's actually the
best move because if i move my rook i
lose my knight
yeah i'm damn okay so that i i thought
maybe there was something i was missing
on wide on youtube oh i missed it
yep i believe it or not i do miss moves
and i lose games
that's [ __ ] i honestly cannot even
believe that
yeah now i'm [ __ ] completely if i move
my rook i lose my knight i'm gonna try
to save my knight
but now you can combine a bunch of ideas
if you play the right next couple of
moves you just put me away
yeah well so is this in this situation
though i just take this rookie take with
you
i can't put you in check again because
it's protected by the knight is that
still the progression i'd want to look
at
yeah first take what's given again take
the rook that's given to you and then
think again about how you want to open
up the position
revisit some ideas that maybe you had
previously
okay
because again you have all these extra
pieces but unless files are opened
you're not going to be able to exploit
them so then i still just want to free
up this file by pushing this pawn up
yeah and i'm actually not going to say
anything after i take this pawn i want
you to find basically the crushing
couple of moves here
and you have several ways to do it
yeah so it's taking with the queen first
and then i can immediately look to
threaten so
you're forgetting about something we
talked about what is the queen doing to
the knight on f6
it's pinning it yeah yeah but but what
did we
specifically mention in regard to pins
what nature
are they they're temporary which means
you need to exploit them as efficiently
as possible and the best way to attack a
pinned piece is with what piece
ah the pawn means that's right
so you see a direct application of pins
in a different context
and i i'm losing my knight now the rest
is just a matter of
easy mopping up and just taking
everything yeah so there's no reason
here why i wouldn't want to just take
your night with my queen right for that
free check go ahead doesn't matter which
piece you take it with you can take with
the pawn you can take with the queen you
can take
all sorts of free stuff you can keep
checking me at some point again it stops
mattering as long as you make
sensible moves within like the top 10
choices you'll you'll be fine
okay so then this is this is good
practice then so then what i immediately
looked at was g
g7 for my queen deliver a check take the
pawn on g6 take this pawn that's given
to me over here on
uh f4 after that and just go around that
way
amazing and actually you're driving my
king to the back rank
so you can deliver essentially i'm going
to try to stop you but
my empire here is crumbling so go ahead
and start taking [ __ ]
yeah so delivering this check here is
not worth it because then you just get
well
do i still win that rook because you
can't protect it right now i deliver a
check
okay do that too you can do that too
you're seeing that you're seeing a lot
of good stuff see i'm not used to you
noticing
that you don't want to take the pawn you
want to win the rook instead that's
tactical progression right there
remember how often we talked about
tunnel vision like not looking at the
pawn looking at the bigger pieces now
you're doing that pretty seamlessly
okay well that's good exactly right in
the field for whatever reason people in
my chat are impressed with you here so
well initially i didn't think i could
make that move because i thought you
could tuck yourself away onto
b8 but i recognized you couldn't do that
so yeah exactly
okay so then in a situation like this i
tend to the immediate problem which is
the rook that's being threatened right
tonight i want to just get the rook out
yeah yeah you don't want to just give up
pieces for no reason
you could give up that rope and afford
it but no need to just
throw around pieces it's not very good
practice in general
uh
anything coming to mind okay yeah but
i'm looking for a way to set up a
checkmate and nothing's coming to mind
yet but maybe that's the wrong way of
playing maybe i do just want to start
snatching pieces and then just play it
by ear that's exactly the right move
because you notice the queen you have a
knight knight and the queen are the
fastest path to checkmate you activate
your knight
great move
now you want to go in for the kill just
take what's given and activate that
knight of yours
and then once that knight is activated
then you can start slowly looking for
ways of delivering checkmate and then
just following along with what i had in
my head yeah
bingo now you have made in two moves but
i don't wanna i don't want you to lose
on time so you know
look for it for 10 15 seconds but if you
don't find it just keep taking stuff
okay but i think you'll find it yeah i
think so it starts with the queen going
to b7 that puts in check that forces the
king
what did you say yeah i said exactly
that's right
i thought you said no well it would be
in my interest to say no but
unfortunately i
i'm too nice exactly nice
okay so basically seamless with the
exception of that move bishop f4
right which which is the product of a
very simple product of just not
asking yourself what i wanted with that
move rook g8 so remember
when your opponents play a move like
rook g8 it's usually because they have
no idea what to do
okay but you it's a good practice to
still
always suspect that they're up to
something they make a move like rook g8
they move upon
unobtrusively some players actually know
how to set traps
so you don't just want to ignore their
move um
and play as if they had not made any
move at all
so that's really the only takeaway other
than that you played fantastic chess
thanks man i appreciate that anime girl
says now charlie's ready to take on
hicario
basically yeah i'm getting there i mean
i did exploit a hanging piece that not
even a grand master noticed
exactly yep i think you should frame
that on on your wall actually
yeah i'm just gonna like clip that and
just have it as like some distributory
material or something in a folder tucked
away
yep the one you take out and you have a
bad day and you really just want to
quickly and efficiently you know finish
the job
of course i made a move that grand
master didn't see
daniel said he didn't see this pawn but
i saw it
[Laughter]
so armed with the confidence that you
can see mr grandmaster's miss
i think uh people in the regular pool of
players are just cowering in fear at the
side of you
so yeah bellerin the boys aren't ready
let's
uh fry up some ballerina
that'll happen
we're on the cusp oh mega man wow that's
almost a thousand rated player these
these people are like
ludwig strength so let's see how you
handle that
okay
now what i was going to ask since four
nights is the most common down here
is there a line to play that's like a
really good
counter to it or is it best just to stay
with just the standard the classic here
oh you mean with black well or on either
side for fortnite
just a line that would be like a nice
count or anything
for now you just want to stay with the
classic i think you're the way you're
developing is good
now he just made the move knight but
we'll talk a little bit about that after
the game now
i i'm worried that you're not going to
find the right reply here what is wrong
with this move knight t4
right well it gives him a hanging pawn
over here on e5
that took you like two seconds to detect
which is what i like the most
a lot of it's a lot of patterns because
you can immediately recognize when this
knight moves that pawns first exactly
that's pattern recognition like when you
first start playing chess
like how the [ __ ] do these gm see this
in like two seconds
but now you can see the progression you
see more and more complicated stuff
faster and faster
so that's really what it means to be
good at chess it's not like the logic in
your mind is better necessarily it's the
pattern recognition right so that had
the nice benefit of getting the night
off there as well
uh it's at this point i just want to
keep developing normally right
yeah walked by the center gas i mean
whatever your hud desires here in
whatever order
yeah good i would even play d4 i mean
but d3 is not it's a solid move
i mean you protect that pawn on e4 but
if you were really ambitious you would
occupy the well okay actually your move
is good because now you don't have to
worry about the pawn on e4
yeah so what uh the reason i played d3
even when that's open is because the
sometimes i forget my c4 bishop is
hanging if it falls under attack
and that's d3 protects that sense not
nothing wrong with that at all
but since my knights there occupying it
it wasn't hanging so there really wasn't
a reason to play it exactly yeah
exactly but that's that comes back to
what we discussed you want to play with
an abundance of caution and there's
nothing wrong with that for now you're
not steinitz
right so in this position do i want to
develop normally and he takes on his own
if he wants or don't worry
about it let him take i mean we talked
about the pawn structure if he wants to
move his bishop a million times to
introduce an imperceptible weakness in
your pawn structure let him
let him do it so just keep developing
but be careful because this knight on e6
is unconventionally unconventionally
placed
yeah it's protecting where i typically
would put over there either f4
g5 so you'll have to improvise and find
an atypical square for your bishop or
not develop
your bishop at all just yet you have
many choices here i still
you can i typically like to develop
though so i was going to go e3 for the
bishop to look to maybe
that's fine perfectly fine move after
the game
i'll show you how i would have
approached that position but it's not
terribly far different from the way you
have so bishop b3 is
perfectly good move my guess is going to
take your knight people usually when
they develop on before they think
they've achieved something when they can
double your pawns
yeah um
anyways yeah he's okay not yet
captain i just want to castle still just
make him take the night if you want to
yeah let him remember that tension
people get
get anxious when they have this tension
on the board and they're tempted to
resolve it
so you have there we go i know these
flares
you and me both man all right so now i
have the b file freed up
uh would you be good for an attack at
some point potentially yeah
okay she's attacking her knight let's
i like to move it yeah so now there's no
real active squares to put them up here
up front so i just need to drop them
back right yeah
and again you'll do more of this
retreating move doesn't mean you did
something wrong you've won upon an e5
and now the heroes return home makes
sense
and now you have to start thinking about
plans how are you going to introduce
improve okay well no never mind he
basically forces your hand
that's another take with that pawn yep
yep yep he's gonna take with his knight
this would be another great example of
when a retreating move is actually the
best move
yeah so this is what uh what i
immediately saw now that he's
relinquished control over here on this
side i can go g5 with my bishop to
attack queen right yeah but his knight's
still on e6
defending that oh right he still has two
on it right so that bishop g5 is not a
retreating move
now is any pawn hanging is he attacking
a pawn
my c's three is putting pressure on
anything else you're not attacking but
putting pressure on anything else that
you maybe
don't want to give up so easily yeah so
could you defend both at the same time
yeah just bringing the queen up there to
d2 but then you don't but but
you don't want to give up your bishop at
all you want to keep both bishops on the
board
uh so just bringing it up to protect the
hanging pawn over there at d4
but that you really don't like
retreating moves jesus bishop d2
it's dropping it down no and i it's good
for me this is good inside i think
you sometimes automatically even if you
want to find a move like this your brain
rejects it like that bishop d2 but
the reality is you disarm that knight on
d5
and that bishop will freaking deliver
the freaking final blow in this game
this isn't a concession of any sort is
what you need to understand
okay now so why would d2 with the queen
protecting both not be the right play
just because i don't want to give up the
bishop at all
exactly you're up upon but you have
what's called the two bishop advantage
you don't want to easily give up either
bishop that dark squared bishop mark my
words
can become very very strong in just a
couple moves if you play this right
okay and the same principle applies here
he wants to triple your pawns by taking
your bishop you don't want to let him do
that
yes i just want to get the bishop out
and go
so i want to keep him on the same
diagonal though right because i'll hold
that pawn
and the square that you want to move it
to is very protected so
yeah if you put it on b5 it could be
liable to be trapped by
your opponent's pawns so he's not
playing badly here you can see that
these guys
it's not like they blunder on every move
but they also don't have any serious
ideas they
they make whatever move tempts them in
the moment they don't have a coherent
sequence of moves they're trying to make
if you develop some sort of a plan to
improve your position systematically
you develop you know you have a big leg
up on them
makes sense to me so
yeah um okay good move he's made a good
move now you cannot
save that bishop but it's fine he's made
a million night moves
to take that bishop you made him work
for it that's okay
yeah again by him moving that knight
that frees up my initial idea exactly
that's exactly what i was hoping you
would say nice now you activate your
bishop you see
you retreated now you attack
and um that bishop on b3 with its dying
breaths
it's pinning that pawn on f7 okay now
you have a great opportunity to make a
general improving move
that i think earlier would not have come
to mind but now
you are sufficiently good enough to
realize that sometimes you just have to
put your pieces on better squares
and which piece in particular can access
a very nice
open post for itself yeah so what i was
looking at
the second he moved that queen there was
looking at e5 for my knight attacks the
queen and it's still looking at that
pawn on f7 but
it doesn't develop any of my pieces
that's unemployed right now
you have several of them you have a
piece that's like unemployed and you can
employ it
asap it's it's freaking knocking on the
door of the employment agency
look at that rook on f1 yeah so it's
still tucked behind that pawn so just
giving it on the e file
yep and you can see that the e7 square
is potentially
accessible to that rook so this move
like rookie one
is a move that beginners don't normally
play because
it's not natural to activate your rooks
but you see why this move is good right
you put the rook on an open file
which way do you take i want to take on
we'll take it towards the middle center
towards the center exactly it takes me
through now you have a nice compact
little pawn mass
and you can start thinking about
attacking the king's side but first
attend to the immediate threats
he's attacking your pawn yep see two c3
is still hanging
uh pushing it up protects it can't
attack the knight exactly the best
freaking move
and then you can slowly start
accumulating pieces on the king's side
which by the way is completely bare
so he thinks this king is safe behind
that pawn cocoon it's not
oh wow jesus christ who does he think he
is
he's asking you to win that night yeah
so where do you put your queen um
yeah i can just bring the queen well i
can bring the queen to d2 to attack that
knight that knight has nowhere to go
he's put it right in the freaking palm
of your hand there
so a move like that to recognize that
it's immediately trapped like
because i didn't initially notice i
thought he still had a retreating screen
i didn't either i just checked the
retreating squares i mean
it's not like i i abra collaborated my
way into this
is b5 defended is d5 defended well guess
what genius pushed their pawn to c4 you
did so
it's like you know i also have to check
certain things sometimes there's a
hidden retreating square like on a4
but that's also defended sorry was that
what you were gonna ask is there some
method of determining
that yeah like how would i go about like
finding when a piece is trapped because
going inside of that pawn structure i
can immediately recognize is pretty
ill-advised but i wouldn't recognize
right away that it's trapped with one
move well that's exactly it if it's
ill-advised then it's a precursor to
being trapped so my intuition already
suggests that it's trapped
and then you brute force check it okay
he takes and he's down a piece
yeah so do i wanna um so this gives me
e7 here since the queen now doesn't have
that control to have rook i have bishop
what do i want to go in with
well what do you think i was thinking
bishop because it attacks
brook but what was that yeah you can do
that
that's fine either move is fine actually
so i'm rushing you because you don't
have much time left
okay all right i'll just do bishop since
that's what i initially said
oh yeah the other thing i was looking at
was rook because then i can attack more
pawns all at once
you can do that too but once he moves
his rook to e8 which he's gonna do in
about three seconds
my bishops pin to it it's not pn's you
can still move your bishop away you can
actually reroute your bishop to a very
nice parking spot a long diagonal where
it aims at
the g7 pawn do you see how you can go
about doing that
where could this bishop park itself in
order to aim at the king
remember the bishop is a long range
piece so it doesn't have to be on the
king's side
to attack the king's side so we can just
drop it all the way back there to a3 and
then b2
but that's a two move combination that's
fine two move we talked about the three
move rule two moves perfect that's
exactly what i thought
okay and then you could stack that
with a queen bishop battery if you put
the bishop on b2 where could you then
put the queen to threaten checkmate
yeah just bring it over there to c3
exactly bingo
you see how you're coming up with these
ideas now two move ideas you're seeing
where the pieces belong
that's completely different stage of
chess mastery then let me just not blow
into a piece on this move
yeah like that's kind of a given now for
you that you're not really plundering
pieces
well there's definitely still those
blunders that happen but mainly it's
when i'm chasing down an idea so at
least my heart's in the right place
right and um you don't want to get ahead
of yourself
to in the sense that two moves idea two
move ideas are
slow you know they're two moves so if
both kings
let's say are super exposed and you're
like oh let me
embark on this four move plan like
probably that's gonna be unrealistic but
remember you're up a piece here
so you can afford to take certain
liberties in positions where let's say
you're up a piece or your king is very
safe
okay that makes sense to me um so i
don't know what
the hell he's thinking about he's
probably
freaking cursing his fate
yeah it seems like an obvious move
though right moving that rook that's
about the only thing you have the only
thing you can do other than giving up
the exchange
you have some five head ideas here that
i will show you after the game
in order to enrich your understanding of
improving peace placement
but the fact that you found bishop a3b2
is already telling
um that's good i had this this might be
one of the five head things you're
talking about but i had kind of a cool
idea to practice
that's kind of that's kind of nice i had
a cool idea to practice one of the
things we talked about which was
dropping bishop
to f6 he takes with pawn which frees up
the g-file which i'd come in with with
the queen
if he takes my queen i win a queen
anyway but
i don't know if that would really lead
to a checkmate in my head i had
something cooked up but
i guess depending on the moves you'd
make it might not work out so
the question off that would be when
would i want to chase down something
like that deep
let me invite you to an analysis board
and we'll discuss that over
wine and cabernet sauvignon and cheese
of course but of course i mean avoid you
two and a board
okay
okay invited so
to answer your question and i'll do that
in a rather roundabout manner
now first of all whenever you're up
material let's say you're up a piece
you need to decide on your risk
tolerance like if
you can avoid sacking a piece in a
speculative fashion you should right
because
if you're up a piece there's really no
need to as my coach would say you're not
writing a book you're trying to win
games okay you're not trying to
well you are trying to impress somebody
but at the end of the day if you're
unsure about a sacrifice
and you're not losing the game then you
know your risk tolerance in chess should
be
moderate but it shouldn't be you
shouldn't go crazy
now concretely the reason i would rule
out a move like bishop f6
right now at this point is because you
don't yet have any pieces on the king's
side
and by what we talked about activating a
rock via let's say a rook lift would
take a little bit too much time
black could bring his queen to g6 so
this would be a little bit speculative
is white much better is he attacking
absolutely
but it would be hard to deliver
checkmate there's no forced mate here
okay but let's imagine that i would
actually lift up this
a1 rook to the king side which you
actually can do this was one of the five
head things i talked about
some people look at this rook and say
this draw could never end up on the king
side but that's what makes a rook so
strong you can
trampoline from one side of the board to
the other in a matter of seconds
and through what square could it access
the king's side
a4 big rook a4
a6 and then rook to h4
stream is frozen one second no it's not
um
that would be an id10tr so rook h4 and
the thing is now you're more ready to
play bishop f6 because you already have
the rook on h where you see what i'm
saying
yeah so let's see if he plays bishop e6
i would now already consider the move oh
my god you have something
wait one second i'm calculating it
if this works it's freaking jizz worthy
sorry
i'm just yep it does actually work
so if you go bishop f6 and he takes it
um
it would be great if this mover
checkmate but the pesky black queen can
now move to f5
and defend g6 remember that bobby
fischer against benko game we looked at
where there was that rook sacrifice
that intercepts one of the defenders do
you remember
what i mentioned there's a direct
application here where you basically
use a rook sacrifice to intercept the
queen what am i talking about
you stop the queen from even getting
there you go rook to e5
exactly and now you can give a nice
juicy little check
what am i talking about right there on
g5 since it's not protected anymore
and now you want to pile up on the h7
pawn with your queen but you want to do
that in a very careful manner
while keeping the f5 square under
control so that black's bishop could not
go there so what square accomplishes all
of that
going knight to d4 to protect that
square
uh again you're forgetting about time
you've sacrificed a rook
too long you you let black take now the
queen you need to threaten checkmate on
this move
threaten check me with your queen
so it's putting a check again at f6 i
could you could but that doesn't
actually do anything i'm going to give
you a hint you want to threaten
checkmate on h7 with your queen
it's a unassuming little move but it it
gets the job done um because it just
threatens checkmate on h7
well bringing the queen was it just
bringing the queen over yeah it's h5
exactly so sometimes you have to make
these moves because black has no defense
if he goes bishop f5 you take the bishop
he goes queen e4 well you take the queen
black can try to run with his king and
now it's checkmated two moves try to
find it
and the first of these two moves is a
little bit of a subtle
little move to show black who's boss
maybe
yeah i think i see it it's just going
queen g5 first check has to fall back
then he goes back we just
we just had this position for some
reason
you have an aversion to mating him along
the h file yeah i guess i keep doing
that huh i guess
the thing i saw was just pushing him
back but then he'd oh good
congratulations
made in two moves so you're already at
the stage where
you need to be seeing the checkmate when
you're saying a first move don't try to
guess your way into this
[ __ ] it's uh that has to start then
with taking the pawn then on h7 so you
deliver check there
that gives him one retreat square and
then he has another retreat square and
you've let him escape so that's why i
said this first move is subtle you have
to push the king back first and then
take the pawn with check mate
so yeah it's h6 first yeah
yeah so what i would actually do and
you know i will make you feel a little
bit better actually finding these types
of checkmates
is harder people assume that tactics
that involve checkmate are the easiest
because they end the game immediately
but they're actually the hardest hunting
down the king is a very very
tricky little business as we saw in that
steinert's game right where you had to
find
that one convoluted sequence so
when you're solving problems and you
know you can do this alone
remember when you solved fork related
problems
oh i solved a lot of those bad yeah
you're never gonna forget that
i think that you should do the same
thing with checkmate i think you can
mark
checkmate as the objective in those
tactics
okay let me actually check that myself
give me a second i'm checking if you can
do that so learning
clearance sacrifice discovered attack
four move checkmate yeah so you can
check four move checkmate and advanced
checkmate
and those are those are gonna be tough
but i want you to solve
like 100 200 two rooks everything that
says check made in that giant list of
themes
made in one made into i want you to
check those boxes and solve
200 300 problems on the theme of
checkmate
but you see how much the fork it was
torture in the moment but you see how
quickly you're seeing these forks now
the same thing will happen with these
two three move checkmates you're gonna
start seeing them very fast
yeah that sounds good to me so this
would have been checkmate so you see
then
the relationship between the number of
pieces on the side of the board
and the possibility of checkmating your
opponent rookie 5 is actually
yep let me see if the computer approves
of this move
it does it's the best move in the
position rookie 5. so these rook
sacrifices
um it's you know interception chess is
one of the fields in which an
interception is a good thing
i tell that to jimmy garoppolo but i
don't met your [ __ ] sports bro well
you know
being from um san francisco i've
i've experienced the golden age of
sports in the last couple years
of course of course except the 49ers who
have lost so
essentially the rook lifts can happen
from any side of the board lesson number
one lesson number so you see
how quickly you're identifying the way
the position has changed
and the only other thing i wanted to
point out is
again to remind you moves like bishop d2
do not be afraid to bring your pieces
back
in order to defend crucial squares
because you're going to bring them
forward again later on in the game
yeah i think that's another thing i need
to just work on because i'm always
bringing forward in order to like
stay advancing or protect in some way
but yeah if i brought it forward there
i'd lose it which i didn't even
recognize immediately
right exactly and another thing i would
consider here is actually going c4 and
then bishop c3 bringing the bishop to
this long diagonal
then dropping it back and stacking up
the queen on top of it so that's like a
gm level plan that's like four moves
long
but in any case your move rookie one and
bishop g5 are both excellent
um this is like the second best move
according to the computer so
you're getting better how do you say
what do you say we finish off with one
more display of your mastery
i was having such a good time thousands
of subs were flying in and then you come
back
damn hype is over guys all right it's
all right
you didn't need them put your credit
cards back in into your wallets okay
devin helly what an intimidating thing
okay queen side a rare guest at
the level yes this is odd it doesn't
change the development though right now
i remember correctly
and knight c6 is not the best move but
it's the sort of the training wheels in
so far as it comes to these other
openings are still on so
this is okay okay so then
would it have been better to develop the
other night first then
uh yes it would have because now you see
the problem see he's putting pressure on
your pawn on d5
and my hint is that you want to support
this pawn with another one of your pawns
yeah this is a queen it's not this isn't
it his queen's gambit because he brings
the queen out and then he looks to win
back
a piece if i take this right so you
don't want to take you want to keep that
stronghold
exactly and then you want to keep
developing normally it's a little bit
passive but
your bishop on c8 is a little bit locked
in but that's really a first world
problem so now he's cutting off this
check on e4
wasn't really going to deliver anyway
yeah exactly just keep developing
normally don't
don't be intimidated by his moves
right so this is a cross between a
london system and a queen scan but he's
playing it well but
keep developing okay so
first thing i notice here is e4 is open
here but i don't get too much out of the
position is it something i still want to
think about
or do i just want to keep going where i
first i would finish my development
and again you're black so it doesn't
have to be
super active as long as you castle and
make your king safe you've gotten the
job done so
and again this speaks to something that
i know you don't love to do which is to
develop your pieces
in sort of a modest fashion where can
you move your bishop on f8 to
the e7 go ahead you got to castle first
then you'll think about how to make your
position more active maybe you will put
a knight on e4
that is a nice idea in the future but
let's first attend to the business so
how does the queen's gambit typically
work then i know you play the
e okay he just helped you
how did he help you
he's allowed you what should he take
back with
i should take with the queen right
because i'm developing the queen out
here no but developing the queen in the
opening since when is that a good idea
you can he's allowed you to open up a
diagonal for something else
that bishop on c8 it was blocked by the
pawn on e6 but
why did you play e6 in the first place
did you play it did you play tick with a
[ __ ] queen
if you were to take another queen then
you wouldn't have had to play e6 you you
hyped up the
you hyped it up i thought i was looking
for something big like you made it sound
like it was a huge mistake like oh if
you take with a queen there's a check
made in
only one move well as i as i i apologize
for not bringing you to a state where
you can win with black innate moves
i will i have sinned father yeah i mean
that's that's what happens when you're
barely a gm
right so then typical move i played
developing with this is going to g4
exactly yeah and you're exploiting
the concession he's made so
why do you take with the pawn also
because you keep a stronghold in the
center
you keep some control over the center
okay so in this position i drop it back
hold the pen if he pushes up again
exactly then he weakens his position
further yeah he also can't trap my
uh bishop either he's got the pawns
trapped there he has no pieces to get in
the position there
exactly exactly so this is the sort of
situation when
okay it keeps developing um
what comes to mind for you
well since there's nothing hanging
there's nothing like i can really not to
threaten
at the moment i was just going to keep
developing pieces so
what i was looking at is getting a rook
involved by bringing
sorry to interrupts but i'm excited you
mentioned that
mentioned which part were you excited
about rotating the fact that
the fact you can take out that material
you stored in that folder somewhere
so the the rook move i was going to make
was just bringing rook to e8 look in the
division to threaten on king's side
very nice and another thing is you can
slowly prepare to put a knight on e4 you
can't put it on e4 yet because it has
two defenders
and only one defender on your side the
pawn on t5
but you can prepare it with a very
crafty little move
that rook on e8 can potentially control
the e84 square
what's standing in its way my bishop
okay so where can you could you
talk your that bishop away you actually
have a brilliant tactical idea here but
we'll talk about it after the game what
can you do here
to reinforce your control over that
square and i just dropped my bishop back
to f8 nice and it's again
retreating move but it has a very clear
intention putting that knight on e4
yeah which is a move that i wanted to
make a little while ago but couldn't
make because of the bishops and that
frees that up
you're also creating a threat you have
two pins in this position can you name
them
right now it's the pawn on e3 and the
knight
on f3 so there's a pawn that you're okay
well
he's threatening one of your pawns which
you should defend
so which pawn is he threatening
come on he's threatening not only a pawn
but he's threatening to take it with a
fork
i guess oh because the bishop's still
guarding it right i haven't moved the
bishop so he's just attacking this
c7 can you defend it you have just the
piece to defend it with
do i want to bring the rookie to develop
that very nice and then you can chase
that knight away back to a6
so i was gonna ask you there is a pawn
that used to be hanging
which is now defended only by the knight
on v5 the other two alleged defenders of
that pawn are both pinned
do you see what pawn i'm referring to
yeah it's the d4 yeah so if you chase
them if he doesn't okay he does
man this guy is pretty good but now you
can proceed with your plan you don't
even need to hurry with a move a6
what was your plan in the first place
why did you drop your bishop back to f8
because i still want that e4 yep go
ahead
so another great thing is now his knight
on b5 is kind of stranded
so you're threatening to go a6 and
actually trap it on b5
now this guy is actually playing very
well for his rating so
i'm my guess is he's going to see it but
we'll see
if he makes the correct move in this
position i will start becoming a little
bit suss
but i won't name it in case he's
watching the stream
i will only tell you if he's made it or
not once he makes it because this move
is not
okay okay the narrative the naredinsky
jinx
i present to you i love batman every
time you're like hyping a player up
three hole single and i it happens on my
own stream too even when i'm playing
gm's like
this guy's a god he sees everything boom
blunder's the queen
i love it man i love that so now in this
position now that i'm up a queen now i
just want to make those trades right
yeah i want to take my with night here
clear the cobwebs clear the freaking
cobwebs
okay so i'm going night into night over
here on e5 he takes back
and then get rid of the annoying pieces
like chase away
the pieces that are annoying you one
after the other which is the most
annoying little thorn in your side piece
right now it's that night okay yeah the
[ __ ] out of there
okay so to chase him away what is the
better position to put it do i want to
push my c pawn
doesn't matter doesn't matter yeah
literally preference because
if you notice you might take that pawn
on a7 but that is a very
similar move to what your opponent did
in the previous game
puts the knight in a compromised
location and you can trap it with what
move
and that's exactly what will happen in
the game how can you trap this knight
no i'm just bringing my rook over right
it has no retreat squares exactly
so game is over well
you will win the night it'll be up for
queen and this is actually i think a
great way to
round off this session because it will
give you a chance to show me how great
your technique has become
okay well he's doing the right thing
he's taking it at least for a pawn but
yeah i mean it's it's nothing yeah it's
still
it's still a night for a pawn which
isn't great yeah exactly
very nice very nice
yeah he is cursing his face oh what uh
what an effective five-head move
tucking his bishop away and yeah so
well what i was looking at here is just
the simplest thing that's looking me in
the face is going over there to either
h4 or now that he's moved the bishop f6
and look to just go right up there into
these f2 pawn
exactly what you want to do queen f6 is
the best move i was gonna
guide you toward it but you find it
yourself and asking yourself how
his last move has changed the position i
loved that you fit that observation in
he's moved his bishop away from
controlling that square you notice it
and then you bring your queen onto that
square which was recently controlled by
one of his pieces
okay now the question i had is why is f6
better than
h4 it's not really better it's just that
f6 is a little bit more of an
unobtrusive square so
it's less likely you blunder your queen
or it gets in the middle of things
now how has his move weakened his
position
well now he has the uh well not the full
diagonal but he's now
pushed upon away from king's defense
he's got a bishop which is locking him
in here on
h2 okay so i guess what comes to mind in
terms of actually winning this game
well the first thing i looked at was
moving this knight on e4
to c3 to maybe move a rook out but that
probably isn't like a great
it is that so that's the best move in
the position i was going to say is it
yes okay you i mean jesus christ
nice nice nice nice knight c3 because
you're exposing the attack on the e3
pawn again applying that principle
his last move has weakened the pawn on
e3 it is now not defended by any other
pawns
and actually if he plays rookie one you
have
a really nice combination you can
sacrifice temporarily a rook
and crash through and win everything in
return
yeah is it going right through on e3
with that rope exactly and then after he
takes a rook
how do you follow up okay he doesn't
even do that so now he just gives you
everything for free
yeah so this is i guess where the
progression comes into play
do i want to start with this e2 check
with my knife no that blunders the
knight to the bishop
start again don't overthink it take what
is given to you
first everything that's free the free
pieces pawns take them
exactly so you'll worry about the mates
later there's another pawn
now he's either going to blunder the
bishop or if he moves the bishop there
will be another pawn that you can take
here
once you get that over with it because
clarity arises out of the situation
yeah so i just need to take care of this
f4 pawn
well i can't though because of this not
the f4 pawn but there's another fun
yeah the d4 exactly take it then you can
start
tightening up the screws activating your
pieces bringing them to the second rank
go ahead yeah and then uh
so the next move i'd want to make here
is pushing rook to e2 which is exactly
yep discover check winner bingo bingo
even if he moves his king out of the
okay he doesn't go ahead take hunt hunt
on hunt
yeah okay so it's starting to feel a lot
more comfortable yeah i can just tell
you're starting your
your mind is settling on the right move
immediately you don't need to like guide
it
like a broken compass to the right
direction like you don't need to wind
the clock you just
see the move yeah this is feeling nice
right now this has been a very
productive session i
have this session is like one of those
and this is what makes i think just a
try you just can see how much better you
are when you compare your performance
you can just see it it's just obvious so
very well done you want all the games
you're
almost at a thousand which is just
unheard of heights we're getting there
i think your real strength right now is
probably a little bit over a thousand so
again remember when you hit a new high
ups and downs are to be
expected you are going to have a game
with your blunder a piece you're my
going to my old self again do not worry
that is a completely natural part of
growth like
sometimes you roll up and then you roll
back down a little bit but it's not you
rolling back down
it's you kind of reapportioning
space in your brain for you know when
people like have brain damage again
there
the remaining part of their brain
reapportions itself
to fill all to fill the space it like
tightens itself so the same thing
happens when you learn
all of these new skills sometimes take
the place of simple things like checking
for blunders
so some stupid [ __ ] is to be expected
but
you know once you get that down you
fully stabilize on the next level
and i think you just did thanks man yeah
that was a very
very laborious way it was laborious
well i don't know any other ways of
coming i don't want you to get full of
yourself so i have to
temper it with brain damage analogies
which of course
you understand because they're near and
dear to your heart yeah
naturally they make sense to me of
course yeah
hit close to home didn't it so awesome
how do you feel
how do you feel playing these games you
feel more confident i assume from what
you just said
absolutely yeah these have felt
significantly better i also think after
the tournament taking a couple days off
was great
absolutely recharging come in with fresh
eyes absolutely recharging the batteries
and um onward to
to crater heights so well done today
that was awesome um
and my recommendation in the meantime if
you if you have the um
you know the time and the desire to
torture yourself
checkmate puzzles should be your top
priority right now in terms of tactics
and in terms of move order and the order
in which to do things finding more
complicated plans that's
our next project and once you get that
down you're a full-fledged club player
my friend so
paradise is on the way can't wait man
yeah i appreciate it i'm looking forward
to our next session
me too me too will be in touch i'll let
you enjoy the rest of your night and
your stream
i'll kick some subs ass because uh
i uh i can't go more than an hour
without filling my own ego
but um this was a great session i'm i'm
legitimately pumped so
uh good luck solving and uh me too i'm
looking forward to the next one as well
awesome man well i'll talk to you soon
bro all right have a great night